different things so like men don't care  about your money they don't care about  your career they don't think no they  don't care about they don't care about  what you do but I think you still need  to do that for yourself I mean you can  do what makes you happy yeah but it  doesn't but no okay that's terrified no  sorry you're right you're right actually  you're correct you're correct but I'm  saying like like don't complain about  the results though so if you want to do  what makes you happy don't complain  about the results yeah so like I mean  you can you can you can like become the  guy but like men don't like guys they  like women some men like guys yeah you  don't